>> WE ARE BACK WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN COMPARING THE
GRADIENT BORDER CRISIS TO OURS
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER, LISTEN
TO THIS.
>> THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE SO
MANY, SO MANY UKRAINIAN SEEKING
REFUGE IN THIS COUNTRY OF
POLAND.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE, AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER AT
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE A DAY
LITERALLY NOT FIGURATIVELY,
TRYING TO GET INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT WE THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD DO OUR PART
RELATIVE TO UKRAINE AS WELL BY
OPENING OUR BORDERS TO ANOTHER
100,000 PEOPLE.
>> MORE THAN 3 MILLION REFUGEES
HAVE ALREADY ESCAPED UKRAINE
WITH 2 MILLION SEEKING ASYLUM IN
POLAND.
IN THE MEANTIME THE CRISIS AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER CAN GET
WORSE NEXT WEEK WHEN A TRUMP ERA
POLICY IS SENDING AS MANY AS
170,000 REFUGEES TO OUR PORT OF
ENTRY.
I AM GOING BALLISTIC OVER THE
COMMENT OF THE COMPARISON OF A
WAR IN UKRAINE, MR. JOEY AND THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
DO YOU SEE THAT SAME COMPARISON
ARTICULATED BY THE GUY WHO IS
OUR PRESIDENT?
DO YOU SEE THE COMPARISON?
>> LISTEN, LEO IT HAS BEEN A
HECK OF A WEEK.
IF THIS WAS A LITTLE BIT LATER
IN THE EVENING AT PROBABLY IS A
DIFFERENT WORD TO DESCRIBE IT.
IT'S FUNNY AND ONE HAND BUT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRAGIC IN ANOTHER
PARADE THIS IS A PERSON WE NEED
TO LEAD OUR COUNTRY.
I MEAN KAMALA HARRIS GOES OVER
THERE IT MAKES AN ABSOLUTE FULL
OF A SPREAD WE HOPE THE
PRESIDENT GOES OVER THERE WITH A
LOT OF PREP KNOWING WHAT HAD
JUST HAPPENED.
INSTEAD WE HAVE A COUPLE DAYS
WERE ALMOST EVERYTHING HE SAID,
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS HAD TO FIX,
CORRECT, OR PULL BACK ON.
AN OUTWARD LOOK AT THE ONE
DOMESTIC POLICY AMERICANS CARE A
LOT ABOUT HE CAN GET THAT RIGHT
EITHER.
HE CAN'T TALK ABOUT IN ANY WAY
PEOPLE COULD UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WE HAVE AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER A LOT OF PEOPLE TRY TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE PROSPERITY
OF OUR COUNTRY AND THE WEAKNESS
OF OUR BORDER.
BUT THEY HAVE THE POLISH BORDER
PEOPLE LITERALLY RUNNING FOR
THEIR LIVES.
NOT WRITING FOR A BETTER LIFE,
RUNNING TO BE ALIVE IN THAT IS A
PROBLEM.
>> AND KATY, TITLE 42 WILL
EXPIRE MARCH 30.
THAT TRUMP POLICY THAT CAP
PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY THEY
ARE COUNTING DOWN THE DAYS
BETWEEN NOW AND MARCH 30 IN
ORDER TO COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
WHAT IMPACT DO YOU SEE ON THIS
HAPPENING?
>> WE ARE GOING TO NEED WORDS
WORSE THAN CATASTROPHIC TO
DESCRIBE WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WERE THINKING 8000 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS EVERY DAY WILL START
CROSSING AFTER TITLE 42 IS TAKEN
OFF.
THE COMMENTS IN THE COMPARISON
MADE BY PRESIDENT BIDEN ARE
ABSOLUTELY ASININE.
IT'S HAPPENING AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS A RESULT OF OPEN
BORDER POLICIES AND
MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISES MAKING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS
A RESULT OF BAD POLICY DECISIONS
THAT COULD BE CHANGED PRETTY
SIMPLY PREDICTABLE BY
DEMONSTRATION IS AMONG A BORDER
PATROL THEY HAVE NOT CHANGED
THEIR PERSPECTIVE DESPITE THE
FACT PORTABLE AGENTS ARE SEEING
VIOLENT CRIMINALS WITH
CONVICTIONS OF THE OFFENDER,
MURDER COMING BACK AND FORTH
INTO THE COUNTRY THAN GOING INTO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE SEE ALL
AROUND AMERICA.
AND YET THEY HAVE NOT CHANGE
THIS PARADE THERE IS NO THEY
COULD STOP THIS TOMORROW.
INSTEAD THEY'RE CHOOSING TO
ENABLE IT.
>> CONCUR ONE 100%.
JACKIE, LOOK INTO YOUR CRYSTAL
BALL.
AS NOVEMBER OF 2022 MIDTERMS JOE
BIDEN TRIES TO CONFLATE THE
PLIGHT OF THE UKRAINE WITH AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER AS KATY SAID
HAVE GANG MEMBERS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER FOR THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC MIGHT BE SYMPATHETIC TO
THE CREATING PEOPLE, DO YOU
THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE SYMPATHETIC TO THOSE
CROSSING THE SOUTHERN BORDER
ILLEGALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
MIDTERMS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I THINK IT'S PREPOSTEROUS THAT
WHAT HE'S DOING AND MAKING THE
COMPARISON.
IT'S NOT SAYING THERE AREN'T
SOME PEOPLE COME ACROSS THE
BORDER FACING CERTAIN HARDSHIPS
BUT TO COMPARE THEM TO THE
REFUGEES IN POLAND THAT
LITERALLY ARE HAVING THEIR
CITIES BOMBED AND SHELLED THAT
BEEN FORCED TO FLEE AS A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT STORY.
AGAIN WE TALK ABOUT WORDS
MATTER.
ANALOGIES MATTER.
THIS IS OUR COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
THE ONE THING I WILL SEE IF HE
DOESN'T SOMETHING ABOUT THE
BORDER AT LEAST HE ACKNOWLEDGED
HERE HE UNDERSTANDS THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ARE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER EVERY DAY.
THAT'S THE MOST I'VE HEARD FROM
HIM ON THIS ISSUE BUT MAKING
THAT ANALOGY WAS ABSOLUTELY
WRONG FOR YOUR QUESTION ON THE
MIDTERMS I THINK PEOPLE ARE
WATCHING ALL THIS PLAY OUT THERE
WATCH THE BORDER CRISIS.
ALL OF THESE ISSUES ACROSS THE
GLOBE.
IT IS GOING TO COME OUT IN THE
POLLS.
>> I AGREE PER JOE BIDEN
UNDERW